حضروا منتجات روسيا النفطيه يدخل حيز
التنفيذ باوروبا ومخاوف من حدوث عجز
بالوقود
يحذر من عواقب اي هجوم على القرن وكندا
ترسل دبابات ليبورد الى اوكرانيا
بعد اسقاط المنقاد الصيني بكين مستاءه
ودول غربيه تؤيد قرار واشنطن باسقاطه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى هذه النشره حضرت وزاره الطاقه المجريه
من حدوث عجز في الكميات المطلوبه من
الوقود في اوروبا بعد بدء فرض سقف السعر
الجديد على النفط والمنتجات النفطيه
الروسيه قالت الوزاره ان شراء الاتحاد
الاوروبي للمنتجات النفطيه من مصادر اخرى
كالهند والشرق الاوسط والصين بسبب
العقوبات على روسيا قد يسبب اضطرابا في
امن الطاقه لبعد او لبعد تلك المصادر
وغلاء اسعارها اوضحت الوزاره ان بودابست
عرضت منذ البدايه توسيع نطاق العقوبات على
روسيا بحيث تشمل قطاع الطاقه لاعتمادها
على تلبيه معظم احتياجاتها من الطاقه على
النفط الروسي القادم يدخل القرار الاوروبي
حيز التنفيذ اليوم الاحد الذي وافق عليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعات السبع
واستراليا حيث سيتم حظر استيراد النفط
المنتجات النفطيه الروسيه
مئه دولار لبرميل الديزل وخمسه واربعون
للفيول وغيره من المنتجات النفطيه منخفضه
الجوده هذه هي الاسقف التي قرر الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرضها ابتداء من الخامس من
فبراير
على ما تصدره روسيا من مشتقات البترول
الاوروبيون سيسمحون للبلدان غير الاوروبيه
وشركات نقل النفط التي تتعامل مع روسيا
ابراما عقود التامين والتمويل مع مؤسسات
غربيه فقط اذا احترموا السقف المقرر
اوروبيا حسب مراقبين فان الرد الروسي على
العقوبات الاوروبيه سيكون بسيطا لكن صارما
موسكو ستوقف او تحد من تصدير الديزل
لاوروبا التي تغطي نصف حاجياتها من روسيا
وبالتالي ستتعطل مصانعها وستقف الشاحنات
والحاف
امام محطات الوقود
البدائل المتاحه لاعضاء الكتله الاوروبيه
كلها بعيده وغاليه ومعقده لوجستيا اذا ما
لجات لاستيراد الديزل وغيره من مواد
بتروليه من بلدان كالهند والصين وبالتالي
ستكون الاقتصادات الاوروبيه اذا ما طبق
القرار اول متضرر من العقوبات
اقتصادات ما زالت تعاني من ازمه الغاز
الروسي التي ادت الى رفع تكلفه التدفئه
وانتاج الكهرباء في اوروبا بعد قطع روسيا
الامداداتها من الغاز المسال فستكون
اوروبا حسب متابعين كمن اطلق النار على
رجله مرتين
انس نماسي العربيه
اكد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي دمي ديف
ان القرم هي روسيا والهجوم عليها يعني
هجوما على روسيا وتصعيدا للنزاع مشددا
ايضا عبر تغريده على حسابه في تويتر ان
القانون الدولي يحترم اراده الشعب
في الاثناء اعلنت وزيره الدفاع الكنديه
انيتا اناند عن ارسال اول دبابه 2 الى
اوكرانيا وذلك ضمن سلسله الدعم بالدبابات
وتضامن اوتاوا مع كييف في الحرب ضد روسيا
بحسب الوزيره الكنديه التي شددت على
مواصله تزويد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بالمعدات العسكريه اللازمه للانتصار في
الحرب
الرئيس الاوكراني
اقر بان الوضع يتعقد على الخطوط الاماميه
في مواجهه القوات الروسيه اما المستشار
الالماني
فاكد من جانبه ان هناك توافق مع زيلينسكي
على عدم استخدام الاسلحه المزوده من الغرب
لشن هجمات على الاراضي الروسيه
[موسيقى]
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقرير يوثق خسائر
اوكرانيا البشريه
الوضع الاوكراني واحد من ثمان حالات طوارئ
صحيه حاده عالميا
اكثر من اربعه عشر الف قتيلا ومصاب من
المدنيين و17 مليونا بحاجه لمساعدات
انسانيه
سبعه ملايين ونصف المليون اوكرانيا مشرد
في انحاء اوروبا
[موسيقى]
448 هجوما بالاسلحه الثقيله على منشات
الرعايه الصحيه باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تقرير منظمه الصحه اشعل مواجهه جديده بين
واشنطن وموسكو
موسكو شككت بدوافع التقرير السياسيه
ووصفته بالمعتمد على روايه الجانب الواحد
فيما دعت واشنطن الى سرعه تحديثه لتوثيق
الحوادث في اوكرانيا منذ سبتمبر
اعلنا زعيم حزب الوطنيين الفرنسيين وعضو
البرلمان الاوروبي السابق فلوريان فيليبو
ان انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيضعف اوروبا وسيخدم فقط مصالح الولايات
المتحده فيليبو حذر من قبل اوكرانيا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه سيزيد من حده
الصراع الاوكراني هذا واشارت المفوضيه
الاوروبيه الى انكييف في المرحله الاوليه
من تلبيه جميع شروط الانضمام تقريبا
وستقدم المفوضيه مره اخرى تقييماتها حول
استعداد اوكرانيا لبدء المفاوضات في خريف
العام الجاري
افادت وسائل اعلاميه سودانيه بان سته
مبعوثين دوليين سيزورون العاصمه الخرطوم
يوم الاربعاء القادم لدعم العمليه
السياسيه وبحث استئناف للمساعدات للبلاد
وذكرت صحيفه السودان تشوبيون ان وصولا
المبعوثين الدوليين يتزامن مع زياره وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف الذي سيصل
الخرطوم ايضا في نفس الوقت لاجراء محادثات
مع مسؤولين في مجلس السياده والخارجيه قال
والي جنوب كردفان موسى جبر ان الاوضاع
الامنيه تحسنت بعد اعلان حاله الطوارئ في
الولايه منذ عشره ايام وشدد على ان حكومته
لن تسمح بالتفلتات والسرقات وقطعت الطرق
التي اكد انتشارها في الفتره السابقه
اصبحت التقارير اللي تجينا من المحليات
تؤكد انه في تحسن كبير جدا عكس ما كان قبل
اعلان حاله الطوارئ
ليستنا مستمره وفيها
رئيسه وزراء فرنسا تقترح تخفيف اصلاح نظام
المعاشات التقاعديه
اهلا بكم اعلن رئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن
ترودو ودعم بلاده للقرار الامريكي باسقاط
منطاد المراقبه الصيني والذي يمر بالمجال
الجوي الامريكي والكندي اكد ايضا مواصله
التعاون المشترك بين الدفاع الجوي
الامريكي الشمالي والكندي لحمايه اجواء
البلدين
قبل ذلك اعربت بكين عن استياائها الشديد
من قرار البنتاغون باستخدام القوه في
مهاجمه منطادها متهمه الاداره الامريكيه
بالمبالغه في رد الفعل وانتهاك الممارسات
الدوليه بشكل خطير وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه
في بيان
ستحتفظ بالحق في اتخاذ المزيد من الردود
الضروريه
واتهم مسؤول في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
اتهم الصين بانها تمتلك اسطولا من مناطيض
المراقبه للتجسس في سماء خمس قارات وقال
المسؤول الامريكي لوكاله رويترز ان
المنتدى الصيني الذي اسقطه الجيش الامريكي
هو واحد من ذلك الاسطول واضاف ان المنطاد
لم يكن مرتبطا بالارصاد الجويه بل ارادت
الصين استخدامه للتجسس على مواقع عسكريه
حساسه ونقل مسؤولون امريكيون عن الجيش انه
سيحاول سريعا انتشار المكونات الرئيسيه
لمنقاد المراقبه الصيني من بين الحطام
قباله سواحل ساوث كارولاينا بعد ان اسقطته
طائره مقاتله من طراز اف 22
هكذا انتهت قصه المنطاد الصيني في الاجواء
الامريكيه صاروخ واحد اطلقته طائره اف 22
اسقط المنطاد في المياه الاقليميه
الامريكيه قباله سواحل كارولانا الجنوبيه
وذلك بتوجيه من الرئيس جو بايدن كما اكد
بيان للبنتاجون
يوم الاربعاء عندما اخبرت بموضوع المنطاد
امرت باسقاطه باسرع وقت ممكن وقررنا ان
يتم ذلك من دون الحاق الاذى باي شخص على
الارض وقررنا ان افضل وقت لذلك هو عندما
يصبح فوق المياه على بعد 12 ميلا
ازمه المنطقه في الاجواء الامريكيه لم تضع
حدا الانتقاد الجمهوريين لاداره بايدن على
تاخرها باسقاطه حيث اتهمها رئيس لجنه
القوات المسلحه في مجلس النواب مايكروجرز
بانها كانت تامل في اخفاء فشل الامن
القومي عن الكونجرس والشعب الامريكي
الجمهوريون الذي يتحكمون في الكونغرس
واشخاص يحشدون للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله لذا اعتقد ان اي شيء يفعله بايدن
او يفعله الجمهوريون فسيهاجم الطرفان
بعضهما حطام المنطاد المتواجد على عمق 47
مترا سيرسل بعد انتشاله الى مختبر
كوانتيكو التابع للاف بي اي في ولايه
فيرجينيا ليتم فحصه ومعرفه ما قيمه
المعلومات التي صورها الصينيون
المسؤلون في البندقون شددوا على ان
المنطقه لم يشكل تهديدا استخباراتيا كبيرا
للولايات المتحده لاعتقادهم بان
التكنولوجيا الموجوده فيه اقل تطورا مما
تمتلكه الصين اصلا الحسين الطولد العربيه
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
كيف يعمل منطاد التجسس لمحه ادق تظهر
كيفيه استخدام هذه المعدل القديمه في عالم
التجسس الحديث عندما اكتشفت الولايات
المتحده الهيكل الطائر فوق اراضيها امتنعت
عن اسقاطه معلله ذلك بانه لا يشكل اي
تهديد على سلامه الناس على الارض كونه
يحلق على ارتفاعات تتجاوز حركه مرور
الطيران التجاري والعسكري بكثير
المناطيل عاده تعمل على ارتفاع من 24
كيلومترا الى 37 كيلومترا وفي منطقه تعرف
بجاره الفضاء حيث لا تطير الطائرات
التجاريه ابدا على ارتفاع يزيد عن 12
كيلومترا و500 متر
اما بالنسبه للطائرات المقاتله فهي تحلق
بعلو متوسط بين الارتفاعين حده الاقصى 20
كيلومترا بينما ترتفع الاقمار الاصطناعيه
عاده الى 241 كيلومترا ولدت تحليق في الجو
تستخدم هذه المناطيد مزيجا من التيارات
الهوائيه وجيوب الهواء المضغوط التي يمكن
ان تكون شكلا من اشكال التوجيه ويتم ملء
هيكل المنطاد الرئيسي بغاز الهيليوم او
الهيدروجين وهما اخف من الهواء والذين
يعدان وقودا لمحركي المنطاد ويعاد شحنهما
بواسطه الواح الخلايا الشمسيه مناطيض
التجسس تحتوي ايضا على انظمه الرادار
المحموله جوا ذات القدره على تزويد الطاقه
من الارضي بمعلومات استخباريه عن مساحات
شاسعه علاوه على ذلك يحمل منطاد التجسس
كاميرات للرؤيه الليليه والنهاريه وفيما
يتعلق بالبالون الصيني الذي شغل مؤخرا
فحجمه يعادل ثلاث حافلات في حين ان
بالونات الطقس عاده ما يتوسع عرضها الى
نحو سته امتار اذا ماذا يحدث عندما ينهي
المنطاد رحلته اذا لم يتم اسقاطه فسيسقط
تلقائيا في مكان ما
اعلن وزير الدفاع التركي خلوص اكار ان
الوفود العسكريه لتركيا وسوريا وروسيا
ستعقد اجتماعا الشهر الحالي لتطوير الحوار
الثلاثي والذي انطلق نهايه العام الماضي
وبحسب اكار لوسائل اعلان تركيا ستجتمع
الوفود الفنيه من وزارات الدفاع
والاستخبارات مع تاكيده الاستمراريه
الحوار من دون ذكر اي تفاصيل هذا وقد عقدت
في نهايه ديسمبر الماضي في موسكو بعد
اقتراح من الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
مشاورات بين وزراء دفاع روسيا سوريا
وتركيا في اطار عمليه تطبيع العلاقات بين
انقره وبين دمشق
اعلنت قوات الامن التركيه انها اعتقلت 15
شخصا من انصار داعش في اسطنبول واحالتهم
الى السلطات القضائيه وجاء في بيان الشرطه
ان الموقوفين كانوا يعتزمون تنفيذ هجمات
ضد القنصليات الغربيه وتحديدا السويديه
والهولنديه واماكن العباده الدينيه
للمواطنين المسيحيين واليهود في تركيا
وذلك على خلفيه حادثه حرق القران التي
وقعت في ستوكهولم
اندلعت اعمال العنف في فروع عندما واجه
المتظاهرون شرطه مكافحه الشغب
اسوء موجه من الاحتجاجات منذ حوالي عقدين
موجه او مجموعه من المتظاهرين اقتحموا احد
الشوارع واطلق ضباط شرطه مكافحه الشغب
قنابل الغاز المسيله للدموع لتفريق
المتظاهرين هذا ويطالب المتظاهرون
باستقاله الرئيس دينا بولوارتي واجراء
انتخابات جديده مبكره واغلاق الكونغرس
وكانت قد بدات الاحتجاجات في ديسمبر
الماضي عام 20 22 والتي قتل فيها اكثر من
50 شخصا في مواجهات مع الشرطه
اقتراحات رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه لزبيثبون
تخفيف اصلاح نظام المعاشات التقاعديه
للسماح للاشخاص الذين بداوا العمل في سن
مبكره بالتقاعد مبكرا ايضا وذلك بهدف كسب
دعم المحافظين لاصلاح البرلمان الفرنسي
جاء ذلك بالتزامن مع سعي حكومه الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون لرفع سن التقاعد الى 64
لمنع النظام من السقوط في ديون
وسائل اعلام باكستانيه محليه افادت بان
الرئيس الباكستاني السابق برويز مشرف توفي
في مستشفى بدبي بعد معاناه طويله مع مرض
نادر يذكر ان مشرف كان الرئيس العاشر
لباكستان وشغل منصب الرئيس العاشر لهيئه
الاركان المشتركه لباكستان من عام
1998 الى 2001 والجنرال السابع من عام
1998 الى 2007
اعلنت السلطات في تشيلي عن مقتل ثلاثه
وعشرين شخصا على الاقل في اكثر من 250
حريق غابه وسط المدينه مع ارتفاع في درجه
الحراره ومن جانبه اوضح جهاز الوقايه
والاستجابه للكوارث اوضح اندلاع 250 حريقا
خرج منها 80 حريقا عن السيطره
بعد اعلان وزير الرياضه البولندي عن قياده
تحالف من اربعين دوله لمقاطعه دوره
الالعاب الاولمبيه في باريس عام 2024
تواجه كل من روسيا وبيلاروسيا تحديا جديدا
حول تمثيلهما من عدمه في باريس
شعله دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه لعام 2024
تطالها رياح تهديدات المقاطعه بينما تسير
فرنسا على قدم وساق في تجهيزات
الاستعدادات للدوره المرتقبه تحول بولندا
قياده حمله مقاطعه لها من خلال تحالف مكون
من اربعين دوله
هدفنا هو ان الروس والبيلاروس لن يكونوا
حاضرين في الالعاب الاولمبيه من خلال
تحالف واسع برئاسه بريطانيا وامريكا لن
يكون للالعاب الاولمبيه اي معنى على
الاطلاق
تصريحات وزير الرياضه البولندي تاتي عقب
اعتراض كل من لاتفيا وليتوانيا واستونيا
على خطه اللجنه الاولمبيه بالسماحل
الرياضيين من روسيا وبيلاروسيا بالمشاركه
في الالعاب المقرره لعام 2004
محاولات اعاده الرياضيين من روسيا
وبيلاروسيا للمشاركه في المنافسات
الرياضيه الدوليه وان كان ذلك تحت رايه
حياديه يضفي الشرعيه على القرارات
السياسيه والدعايه التي تنشرها الدولتان
تحت وطاه السياسه تواجه دوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه في باريس مصيرا غير واضح اما
اللجنه الاولمبيه فتصمم على ابعاد السياسه
عن الملاعب الرياضيه المقاطعه تعد انتهاكا
للمثاق الاولمبي الذي يلزم جميعا لجانب
المشاركه في الاولمبياد وارسال رياضيات
ويشهد التاريخ ان قرارات المقاطعه السابقه
لم تحقق اهدافها السياسيه وكلما فعلته هو
معاقبه الرياضيين
دعوات لابعاد السياسه عن الرياضه يواجهها
تصميم اوكراني على تنفيذ تهديدها
بالمقاطعه بسبب استهداف نحو 300
ملعبا رياضيا في اوكرانيا الى جانب وفاه
220 رياضيا ومدربا وعاملا وفق تصريحات
وزير الرياضه الاوكرانيه
اما امريكا فتواصل دعم موقف اوكرانيا
المصحوب بحملات مقاطعه اوروبيه واسعه
لتبقى دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه المقبله في
باريس على محاكي تصعيد متزايد ومواجهه في
ملاعب السياسه وضغوطها علي السمان العربيه
في نهايه النشره نذكر بالعناوين
حاضروا منتجات روسيا النفطيه يدخل حيز
التنفيذ في اوروبا ومخاوف من حدوث عجز
بالوقود
يحذر من عواقب اي هجوم على القرم وكندا
ترسل دبابات الى اوكرانيا
بعد اسقاط المنطاد الصيني بكين مستاءه
ودول غربيه تؤيد قرار واشنطن باسقاطه
دمتم في امان الله
[موسيقى]